hey
here we are with the lag again i was
hoping that cord would come today but it
didn't
so you guys will just have to put up
with it yeah for a few more days we'll
see
we'll see if the cord actually fixes the
situation we don't have to buy a new uh
laptop yeah i don't know if it will or
not i mean you know
it wasn't that expensive so hopefully it
won't be like that
trying to get this just started hi clay
hi
people showing up and i mean we are
doing we'll do a live stream tomorrow
but then we probably won't do another
one until
till the regular show on saturday like
normally
it's the length that i have okay there
it is yeah because i started one and
then i [ __ ] it up and i had to
and i had to so there were two links
there were yeah because the first one
that i did was like [ __ ] up and i had
to quit
all right so i had to like yeah we just
did got off of another review that we
reviewed
don't tell anyone i'm not gonna tell you
but you guys are gonna like it that's
gonna go up when
friday well unless you're a patreon in
which case you'll see it thursday
morning
okay um and like i said patrons already
know because i always post like at the
beginning of the week
on patreon patreon what the [ __ ] for the
week is going to be
at least the [ __ ] that i know they're
all pilings
everybody pile in here yeah i was just
telling jenny that uh sources are
telling me that
the disney corporation is in dire
straits right now
and that uh chances are
that disney's gone which that's [ __ ]
bizarre that the company's
that big has been around for so long is
gonna [ __ ] fly apart
but uh they're evidently gonna [ __ ]
massive layoffs
and a real bad uh reports gonna come out
go out to shareholders about how much
money they're [ __ ] losing
chances are [ __ ] disney stocks gonna
plummet and it's
it's already pretty much in a death
spiral overextending itself
building failed theme parks in dubai
spending too much money on star wars
spending too much money on uh what's
that [ __ ] thing on that damn
streaming service that they had
they're not making any money more people
working in the parks than coming to
parks and empty hotels and it's going to
probably go
according to what he says it looks worse
than amc theaters
on paper
clay says where's pookie pokey running
around she just came in a second ago and
then she ran back out again because i
guess we weren't
doing enough to like entertain her
yeah mango said it's a dead duck company
i believe so
one of the titans of entertainment going
down
in flames um the guy who uh
gave the report with you know who has
contacts inside the corporations
they believe that it will be dismantled
over the coming months and sold off
they looking good that's something huh
that part of american [ __ ] history
but then again everything is part of
american history i was just gonna say it
everything goes into the past
yeah i mean that's why i can't really
maybe it's just because i'm getting old
i just can't get all that upset yeah
you're like
[ __ ] it i'm not well i'm not like a real
nostalgic person i've never been a real
nostalgic person
yeah i noticed that so it's just kind of
like um
and the thing about it too is that i
don't i really only try to worry about
[ __ ] that i can like
do something about and i can't do
anything about that i get a certain
amount of [ __ ]
kind of like i get i have a kind of like
an out-of-body experience when i see
things just [ __ ] vanish
you know it's like standing next to a
damn glacier or something and watching
it go by
like watching dead mall videos it's like
damn all that shit's gone
look how big it is that could never fail
oh it failed
i like those but not because i don't
know i'm just not real nostalgic about
it
i mean i feel bad for people that like
lose their jobs and i feel bad for like
the real people whose lives it impacts
but
like other than that i don't really i
don't know it doesn't bother me all that
well
i guess i got my own [ __ ] problem
disney corporation's been [ __ ] up
for the past 20 years anyway i mean you
know the [ __ ] the theme parks are
pretty damn dated when you put it next
to [ __ ]
universal the universal is awesome it
blows disney out of the damn water
and to have a successful theme park you
got to be on top of your game nostalgia
isn't going to bring you through it
anymore well i mean back in the day when
they opened it it didn't have any
competition and now
like orlando is just [ __ ] full of
full sparks and
other [ __ ] you can yeah and you have to
kind of like yeah and look and look at
the difference the last time being at
disney and [ __ ] universal
universal blew disney out of the [ __ ]
water well yeah because they spent a lot
of money on that yeah
just that harry potter virtual reality
ride i was [ __ ] astounded
felt like i was moving all over the
place riding down [ __ ]
broom wind and smoke and [ __ ]
you been on that thing you were on that
thing when i was yes you went on it
that's right we were there at the same
[ __ ] blew me away man
i couldn't believe i wasn't moving it
wasn't moving much but it makes you
think you're moving doesn't it
yeah blowing wind on you they had one
like that at um i don't think it's there
anymore but we used to have mgm
yeah mgm studios and they had a back to
the future wrap up
i think that was at mgm studios and uh
it was like
or maybe it was old universe i can't
even remember i think it was mjm but you
got into delorean
and it was like same kind of thing at 3d
it was woo man
it's just like flopchat all over the
place but it really did look like you
were
going everywhere those kind of make me a
little bit motion sick to be honest i do
like them though
tammy's saying that they were dated and
overpriced that's exactly what they were
yeah and then they changed [ __ ] like
save for safety
reasons like they had to turn the lights
up in the small world ride and when you
had that thing
brightly lit you could see the cheap ass
ceiling and the [ __ ] uh
and the little paper dolls it looks
cheap as crap little
dancing paper dolls they even kind of
lightened up the
haunted house a little bit you could
kind of see the seams and things
i think that still looked good but yeah
that ended up happening i think
particularly in the small world ride
because i think a couple
kids like fell off of there and drowned
or something is that what it was i think
yeah
that was a long time ago if i'm
remembering it correctly i could be
totally wrong but i'm pretty sure i
at least one kid drowned it really it
really only had three good rides splash
mountain
the haunted house and space mountain
that was really i still love the haunted
house
yeah that was really the only reason to
go to disneyland disney world
yeah if you ask me and it's not worth
what they wanted
yeah like i said i was just too like i
said i wouldn't care if if it was that
much to get in if you could like eat for
free all day
right like if you didn't have to pay
restaurants and like [ __ ] on top of it
like if you just got free food
then i'd be like oh okay that's a good
deal because that would just be like one
full day and you could just do what you
wanted
after disney princess is stripped if
they had like an adult
version they have like okay you see the
disney princess and over here man for
for
for all you paying customers you know
then they're going there's like a strip
club
yeah yeah maybe that maybe they should
that's one thing yeah
well remember back in the old days when
they first opened
you actually had to pay to get in it
wasn't super expensive you had to pay to
get in and you had to pay
per ride you had to pay for tickets yeah
and like space mountain and stuff like
that were expensive
like because they took you had to have
like an e-ticket which was like the most
expensive one remember the old she had
to buy a book
a booklet of them remember the old snow
white ride where the [ __ ] screaming
witch came out
at you yeah that used to scare the crap
out of me and the old peter pan one
where you're flying over the [ __ ]
city
and mr toad's wild right yeah i was into
that where you went to hell at the i
don't even think those exist anymore do
they
i think they took them out like one of
them i think mr toad
was gone like a long time ago because i
think they put like a winnie the pooh
thing in there yeah if i'm remembering
i don't know yeah nobody knew who mr
toad was probably by the time that they
took
yeah because that i mean when did the
wind in the willows is like so old and i
don't think it
is why it's not that widely right
anymore no it wasn't even
it wasn't even widely read when i was a
kid remember the 20 000 leagues under
the seas
yeah yeah one that was a [ __ ] fun
with the [ __ ] underwater deck yeah i
liked that
you weren't even deep you weren't even
deep you the thing wasn't under water it
just
the window was underwater the window was
underwater i mean if you went like that
you could see the surface yeah but they
had it dark so you couldn't see this
you couldn't tell then the giant [ __ ]
squid
that stressed me out because like i'm
always like scared of like deep
watership
yeah so any big monster like underwater
was going to scare the crap so i'll just
uh oh six armor says peter pan is still
there is it still there
yeah snow white's not there and toad is
gone i remember when they got rid of mr
toad because i was kind of sad i always
liked that one
yeah even though like i said even when i
was a kid you know
wind in the willows was kind of not
really so i think i read it but i don't
think a lot of kids
mango knows this [ __ ] mango badger knows
this [ __ ] because he brings up all the
details that's right man eiger [ __ ]
overstretched the company
that [ __ ] is going to be leaving
that company in disgrace
they and they they [ __ ] up star wars
that was that was
i think that was the nail in the coffin
because they spent nearly a billion
dollars for that [ __ ]
uh force awakens made good money
uh but but the return slowly declined
and you know
one of them [ __ ] the solo movie it
didn't make any money
and i didn't lost money even though i
didn't even mind that maybe i thought
yeah it wasn't that bad
it's just that you know the the crowd
kind of soured on it um
evidently like the closest thing to the
original star wars is the mandalorian
they say that series is really good
yeah we'll have to watch so they're
going to try to make more mandalorian
wouldn't surprise me if they make a
mandalorian movie and try to get rid of
the whole [ __ ] star wars thing and
we're just gonna
stick with the man the lord that that
would probably make money because they
said the tone they said it was just like
classic star wars
better actually yeah but i haven't seen
it
yeah back when anheuser-busch had
ownership of sea world i don't think
they do anymore um
do they even own busch gardens anymore
like in tampa holy [ __ ] i don't even
remember i mean i guess they do because
i think they sold the clydesdales
i haven't been to busch gardens either
since [ __ ]
the late 90s maybe i just you know we
can't afford to go to theme parks i like
going to theme parks but i just can't
afford it it's a hundred dollars a
person
and honestly if if you're going to go in
florida i don't want to go in the
summertime because once it's too [ __ ]
hot and i'll give it a heat stroke and
two it's too [ __ ] crowded yep
it's better to go in the winter time i
always have a better time if it's like
cold out
yeah it's great times for summertime for
for [ __ ] tourists well yeah because
that's what all they're doing
and that's when all the kids are out of
school so it's like you can come from
around the world
and like you know go there but like i
said you're going to get [ __ ] heat
stroke
you're easy going to spend 200 a person
yeah oh easily easily easily probably
more like 250.
especially if you're eating there yeah
and um because food's not shaped
and disney isn't worth that no like i
said i wouldn't care if it was cheaper
universal was worth that maybe but yeah
i don't even i don't even know about
that i mean yeah it's like it's still a
good time but it's like still just to
get in the door
and there's no alcohol yeah see that's
the thing man
if you if you could drink there for a
reasonable amount of product well now
you can drink it epcot
yeah i thought you could drink it
universal because didn't universal has
uh halloween horror nights and you could
drink at halloween horror nights
you know what i mean okay i guess you
could because i remember a bunch of
drunk ass people running trying to
follow me don't worry
it's i don't know if they do that was a
long time i don't remember any drinking
at disney and you you couldn't afford to
get drunk it didn't well like i said
epcot you can drink
because that was kind of the whole thing
is you'd have to take the monorail over
to epcot
and get schnackert over there and then
come back to disney that was like what
you had that's what you did
right you went over to epcot and got
drunk because they had good liquor over
there because they had like the around
the world thing yeah so you get all the
good german [ __ ]
right imagine if you would imagine if
you went to that theme park on acid
you'd probably like never recover
one of the things that always got me
with those theme parks is they always
seem to close early
it depends on the time of year that's
that's one shitty thing about going in
the winter is they do tend to close
earlier
yeah because it gets dark earlier and
they don't like have a lot of real late
night
yeah i understand it because you know
magic mountain didn't didn't close early
like that you know in california and you
know theme parks are really cool at
night
yeah as soon as it gets dark in
disneyland get the [ __ ] out you got to
go home
yeah sometimes like some nights i guess
in on weekdays
and from what i remember like on
weekdays in winter sometimes disney
would close at like seven o'clock or
some [ __ ] like that i don't know if
that's still the way it is though they
might
stay open later nowadays yeah but um all
right so
you want to actually talk about the
movie now
[Laughter]
now that we're like already this is not
gonna be a complicated [ __ ]
review now so this is okay uh we didn't
know
this and i think you still don't know
this because i haven't told you yet
like um until i researched this movie
because this
came up as a new movie now this just
came out on
dvd blu-ray whatever like in may of this
year from intervision pictures
and it's also free on 2b it's called
masked
mutilator now when we watched it
i thought that it was trying to look
like it was made in 1994 like it was a
throwback type of movie guess what
it is it was made in 1994 except for
the um the bookends like the beginning
and end part like with the guy the
podcaster guy like interviewing the
people
that was just filmed like recently okay
what ended up happening with this movie
was that the guys that made it um
the one guy i think he was like the
co-writer the producer or whatever
um named dale schneck i think his name
is
and he was a wrestling promoter like
back in the 80s and 90s and he had like
all these wrestlers that wanted to be
in movies so him and this other one
uh whose stage name was brick bronski
um he had been in some troma films i
guess he was in class of newcomb high
two and three and [ __ ] like that
so they were trying they were all into
horror movies so they were trying to get
together to do a wrestling themed
slasher movie so it's just not
technically a slasher because the killer
kills people with wrestling moves
which yeah as you should if it's a
wrestling movie i mean you kind of need
to
so they got together in 1994 i feel
hoodwinks now
[Music]
because i was going like man they got
the 80s and 90s toned down
it's like look at those shorts oh my
gosh like look at her hair man she
actually cut her hair like that
now i feel like a [ __ ] dick the whole
time i was watching
we thought they had done like a really
good job of playing and i was going like
i like everything about this but the
score sounds a little too modern and i
bet you they [ __ ] put that score on
it later
i don't know if they did or not because
what ended up happening like i said so
they made like 80
of the movie in 1994.
um then they couldn't get it going they
lost some funding or they couldn't get
enough money or they couldn't finish it
or whatever
and so like it kind of sat for another
two years and they worked on it a little
bit more in 1996
and then they just couldn't like get it
off the ground so it ended up like in
the dude's basement
and he said he felt really bad he's like
all this time like all this footage it
was almost done
and it was like just laying down in my
basement and he's like all these like
actors and the crew and stuff like that
that worked on it
and it's like they didn't even have like
a finished movie like to show their
friends or anything like that like hey
look at this movie i was in
because some of the people that are in
it a lot of them were like kind of
well-known wrestlers and some of them
like went on
to like act in bigger things um you know
and are
fairly well known nowadays so um i
didn't know who any of them were but
i'm watching the movie you know i'm
watching this guy he's probably in his
20s and i'm seeing him pull off a roll
of a guy supposed to be doing this in
the early 90s and i'm like hey he's got
to roll down
we did kind of talk like that or you
know and i was like i bet you he doesn't
even know what he's saying
yeah yeah it's like that she's far from
moved from history he wasn't even born
back then little did we yeah little did
we know i'm [ __ ] watching the dude
i didn't know either to be fair yeah i
was thinking of myself a good movie
though
it is it is it a good movie yeah it's a
good movie
i mean it's a badass but it's a good
movie you know what i mean
it's like it's just kind of like i mean
just imagine what
comes to your mind when you think of
micro budget
yes slasher movie made in 1994
with wrestlers yeah i i thought it was
about
even better than it turned out to
actually be
because i thought they were emulating
1991 or 94 94
87 or something because there's the 90s
still kind of look like the 80s
sometimes
which is funny i'll be able to get out
of their way to recreate that turned out
now that's that was it
which i don't know how to feel about
that yeah now i'm going well especially
the guy
um i think the one guy that was in it
that i think the character's name was
steve right that was played by
brick bronski the guy that comes to you
know the group home
like later on and he's all like college
boy and everything that one
ensemble that he had going with like the
pink
polo shirt and the weird pink and
but like kind of lavender and white
striped shorts that were just like a
little too short
yeah you know what i mean and it's like
there's nudity in the movie though too
man the girls are pretty hot in it
yeah titties you get to see a little bit
of bush we're like a little a little
landing stretch
like you had in the 90s nice [ __ ]
yeah a little landing strip
see the genre's correct
they know who's watching this movie they
know what kind of movie this is
we got to put [ __ ] girls in it just to
get them to watch it you know i mean
they're going to expect that
and so that's what they did so they went
out and probably got some strippers and
had them
do a scene you know yeah get your kid
off as they would say in the uk
yeah but yeah so basically the premise
of this movie
is that there's like a group home for
troubled
teenagers um even though these actors
are clearly all like
30. yeah um and they're supposed to be
under 18 because they make a couple of
things
like they can leave when they're 18
right because i guess they're all
miscreants or whatever criminals or
whatever you can leave home when you're
punching teachers actually you could
depend on what state you were in
you could leave home when you were like
16 or 17. no but i'm just saying that
the characters in this
said that they could leave the group
home when they were 18 which
implies that they're all supposed to be
younger than 18 right
even though the actors are clearly well
over 18. and if they were under 18 then
all that nudity would be a little
problematic wouldn't it yeah
these don't worry these girls do not
even look 18 they look much older than
they
yeah not a bad way but they they're
clearly remember when girls look like
that though the hair
and then they had that [ __ ] douche
bag with that [ __ ] douche bag outfit
yeah remember they got it the douche bag
yeah he turned him to be the bad guy
spoiler well no that's well that was one
thing that i was gonna say
was that so you have a wrestler
um and they call him commando and he has
like a mullet with like a long like
ponytail in the back he's dark-haired
yeah
and he's like the tough guy that's like
beating up all these kids like
you know trying to punch him into shape
or whatever yeah now he
used to be a wrestler called the masked
mutilator
but he lost his wrestling career when he
sort of accidentally on purpose
like broke the neck of the person that
he was wrestling with
it's like it's funny because it says it
they seem to imply that it was
accidental but it totally looked like he
did it on purpose i mean it totally just
went like look i just broke someone's
neck what the [ __ ] you gonna do about it
there's
a [ __ ] ton of movie-ism
they know who you are they know why
you're watching this
they know who you are yeah and they're
doing things they were doing things
in 1994 that go
all the way back to [ __ ] 1974 you
know
in these kind of like there's a lot of
scenes with dudes [ __ ] lifting
and in the gym yeah they're all
weightlifters all the way
like everybody in this movie yeah and
that that's and the wait sets are like
uh good you know places to set up where
people get hurt or killed or
bullied or whatever you know what i mean
it's just it was a movie of its time
when it's doing its deal i was just you
know you start laughing at it
it's like watching under siege you know
or watching you know [ __ ]
what's that other one the [ __ ] uh
blood sport
you know it goes back to that level
bloodsport was silly as [ __ ]
yeah but you still watched it yeah well
that's kind of where this one is coming
from
and it's like they kind of know that
like like i said there's like there's
titties in it there's like there's
little
landing shirt bush in it
there's a couple of kills there's not a
ton of gore there is some
um you know there's people getting like
wrestled to death and like
dudes and there is one part where the
where the guy like cuts the body up
yeah it dudes bowing up and talking [ __ ]
every [ __ ] five minutes
it's very funny yes well i'm just
sitting there going like toxic i'm like
dudes you guys are so sensitive you
can't like say anything you just like
look at them the wrong way and they're
just like i'm gonna kick your ass
i'm like dude calm down god damn it
that's awesome i just want yeah i wanted
to comment on that like so everybody is
like super
buff so you know if there's anybody
that's into like super buff dudes
there's a lot of that
kind of eye candy but you see it's
obvious why they did that because it was
entertaining
and it was free they had guys it didn't
cost anything to give
i won't kill you i won't kick your ass
you know and then they were doing this
yeah then another
[Laughter]
yeah there's a lot of that yeah there is
a lot of that a lot of that yeah and
they're doing it just like indoors in
the house
and uh you better watch your [ __ ]
mouth when you did yeah
oh it's not all the way man it's just
that
yeah it was [ __ ] that [ __ ] that when i
was like 15 or 16 i thought that [ __ ]
was badass
dude with the [ __ ] mullets and [ __ ]
and i cut off [ __ ] shirts and the
[ __ ] shorts
[ __ ] those shorts trunks shorts
yeah i think i think i had a nightmare
about those
only thing missing was the three [ __ ]
stripes on the socks
the knee stocks with the three stripes
yeah that would have those kind of gone
out by the early night right now
but one the movie at times felt like a
early 80s
late 70s movies because the dialogue can
we also talk about
the [ __ ] girl oh yeah yeah um and
that thing that she was wearing that was
like
a teddy but it's like remember how like
in the 80s and early 90s like everything
had those super super high cut
thighs it's supposed to make your legs
look longer
so but it didn't it just made your ass
look longer
it made your ass look flat your ass look
flat and really [ __ ] tall
i don't know who who the hell came up
with that [ __ ]
it's ridiculous so it's like so i so i
feel like kind of because when i saw her
wearing that i was like oh my god i
wonder where they found that but i guess
it's like that's what that was just
that was the normal underwear the french
cut leotards yeah that's exactly what it
was
oh my god it was horrifying unflattering
you brought that [ __ ] into vogue is that
like some [ __ ] [ __ ] olivia newton
john let's get physical video or
something
i kind of feel well yeah i guess it was
well that was kind of like
way before that well i mean that that
did like bring in the whole
like workout gear as regular yeah
clothing
thing you saw in porn too
yeah it was just [ __ ] unflattering
but they wore it anyway
everybody wore it that's like all you
could get it was like the soviet era
that was all you could buy
yeah it's not like now where you can
just get whatever the [ __ ] you want it's
like you just if you went to the store
that's like you we remember what it was
like it was butt floss or nothing yeah
we went to the store and you couldn't
find floss or nothing you could buy
you couldn't buy goth clothes from the
store it was just [ __ ] some [ __ ] that
[ __ ] was that sears a [ __ ] kmart
that at the mall there wasn't any choice
it was just commodity clothes they're
just bulk
clothes these are clothes you wear them
everybody else wears them
there's like it's like soviet russia i
had to order [ __ ] goth clothes from
another country or something
yeah i used rose yeah i had to order
them from blackrock and overseas
yeah so you had just make on your own
but yeah
i've actually been to the black rose
store in camden market
in london it's like it's like an outside
flea market thing but it's there like
shopping sucked back then it did yeah
everything had to be mail-ordered
yeah but yeah so one one criticism of
this movie is that
so they set the masked mutilator guy who
runs this
group home and the the guy that's going
around doing all the killing
and it is death by wrestling like people
do get killed in choke holds
um one guy gets killed by the dude like
grabbing the back of his hair and just
like smushing his face like against and
one guy gets like
hugged to death i guess he kind of like
breaks the spine or something the [ __ ]
is that move called i don't know where
he gets
kind of a bear hug yeah something like
that so he kills a guy like that
but um so they obviously very
obviously want you to believe that the
guy that was the masked
mutilator is the guy doing the killing
but it will be very clear to you within
about
10 seconds of the brick bronski
character being introduced
that he's the killer i mean duh that's
what
you know what i mean it's not even a
spoiler alert because if you watch this
movie you'll be like oh well obviously
because i feel like they were trying too
hard yeah to make
the main guy with the flash dance
sweatshirt
and the mullet as soon as i started
watching this movie i knew it wasn't
going to be some kind of a masterpiece
of [ __ ]
right well yeah obviously that that's
not what they were trying to do with
this
you know what they were trying to do
with this was a slasher
movie on par with bloodsport what
wrestling yeah wrestlers
and so there is actual wrestling in this
like the wrestling
choreography is actually pretty good
because these are actually real
wrestlers i think i think that
the target audience was you know
15 16 17 year old guys that really
didn't want to see
a slasher that they wanted to see more
wrestling and dudes talking [ __ ]
and some naked girls you know what i
mean with occasional slashes
[Laughter]
it's kind of like a horror movie just
stay out of my way you [ __ ]
yeah dudes the [ __ ] that should be
the sequel stay out of my way you
[ __ ]
that was my sister yeah there's a little
bit of that yeah yeah yeah yeah
can i just say that the fact that this
movie
is set in a group home for troubled
teens yeah and
that it includes several large dudes
wearing flannel
this reminded me very much of the
classic that was on mst
future war the one with the guy that
looks like jean-claude van damme
yeah and he is an alien and he comes to
earth and there's dinosaurs also that
are actually just horse perspective
puppets that explode
for some reason and um they did it
and there's like a girl who's a nun
except
not and then there's like a group home
and there's all these big fat dudes
that live in it and wear flannel it's
very weird i remember that they had the
low budget
van damme stan did yeah i liked his name
um he was the fake jean claude van damme
ah i can't remember the actors and the
worst [ __ ] filmography ever man
[ __ ] the angles and this is just
everything this is the worst ever
and i love that on mst they called him
jean-claude gosh darn
so that's how i think about i don't even
remember what is real it's daniel or
something i think
that movie was worse than this one
though yeah that was weird
movie was way worse that movie had
you guys that movie had a guy playing a
newscaster who had a camera
that was just a plastic camera lens
clearly
taped to a cardboard box yeah yeah i
remember that okay
i remember that's what we're talking
about yeah you can't rip two cameras and
put one of them on the [ __ ] screen
you got to make a camera with a carpet
they didn't even like paint it
tv on it didn't it it said tv i think it
said tv but it was clearly a box
they didn't even like paint like didn't
even make it black with a marker or
nothing
yeah it's like they just left [ __ ]
ridiculous man
this one was better that was a great
[ __ ] mst episode though i gotta say
because the movie was just [ __ ]
ludicrous because i think that one came
out about the same time is this one
maybe
i feel like that one was made in the 90s
too that one was incompetently shot
though that was incompetent yeah this
one is competently
this one the only thing about it is that
and i was watching a review of this
earlier by uh
bloodbath and beyond uh their channel
and something that i noticed as well was
that the grain
like from scene to scene is different
yeah and i think that's why
um and i think it's because when they
went back to re-edit it that they
reframed some of the shots so they blew
them up
yeah you know so they could just to make
it look a little bit better so it is a
little inconsistent and obviously they
made two wrap-around segments
um in the present day and i they
actually got one of the same actors back
again
who didn't actually look much older
weirdly it didn't bother me because i
at the time i thought it was a mock
retro movie right
which is very funny that we thought yeah
i was like
loving it it was like man they got the
tone down right yeah that's the way it
looked and
because it is that's what it was yeah it
was a retro movie i know it was
it's weird i never would have guessed
that yeah but i guess now that i've
well because you just never see that
happen when i would have taken the score
out of it though
i would have used like a new retro wave
score yeah that might have worked that
had been a lot better
uh the score that was in it didn't
really work with it too well
i put a new like put a [ __ ] something
you could just source off
you know [ __ ] open source [ __ ]
right off youtube you know
yeah some new retro wave and put that in
there and it would have sounded a lot
better
and um would have given you that fake
retro
feel because that's what it needed yeah
it needed to
it needed to feel like it was fake retro
maybe they should have gone there i mean
they did a little bit because like i
said they shot
the the modern day stuff and then they
the stuff that they shot in 1994
it's almost like a flashback like you
see so you have the same guy
that was in the original movie except
he's you know it's 20 uh years later
and he's telling like a podcaster about
what
about these murders that happened at
this group home that happened to him and
he was like some [ __ ] ed wood would do
it's a good it's a good idea this is a
seed from which a big tree will grow
you know yeah well like i said they had
i'm gonna do a wrap-around story well
the wraparound is only like a couple of
minutes
i mean they had almost the whole movie
done yeah it's just that they
never like had the funds to finish it he
even said like the guy that was making
it he's like it was like 80 85
done and we just didn't have the money
to finish it and we just didn't
so it's like you just never see that
happen where a movie as low budget as
this as independent as this
you know 20 odd years later they
actually finished it and got somebody to
release it
yeah you know what i mean like they got
a little like intervision pictures
who kind of who kind of dig around and
look for like these kind of obscure
you mentioned about the problem with the
movie is though it doesn't have a budget
and because they don't have any money
everything has to be dialogue driven
with some action so with no budget you
that what you end up with is you
guys that are like wrestlers yelling at
each other yeah yeah
and occasional titties and occasional
occasional restaurants and occasional
wrestling and that's what you're gonna
get
and it was entertaining
i found it quite i found it very
entertaining it's entertaining i mean
just just between like the fashion and
the yeah
the dialogue and the haircuts and
thinking that i was thinking that they
were faking it
i thought it was fake retro maybe they
should maybe they should sell it like
that
that's what i would do maybe they should
just not tell people that they actually
did shoot it and they just
repackage that [ __ ] into a fake retro
package because then everybody's like oh
this is a
genius yeah it's [ __ ] cheap
masterpiece
i felt like i went back in time
to everyone wear those horrible shorts
and this i wonder where they got those
outfits and that anal floss
yeah i wonder where they got those
costumes who cut that hair
master hair stylist that just did the
period but yeah
it's like i i found it really
entertaining and i read an interview
with the co-writer and the producer and
he was like super super happy
that you know finally the movie was done
and finally people were going to get to
see it and like that he found a company
that was gonna release it and he seemed
super excited and i thought that was
i thought that was awesome he's like
because all these people worked on it
and never got to see it it was just
sitting in my basement for 20 something
years and he's like and that was a
bummer
so i thought it was pretty cool so like
i said
if you want to throw some money their
way i think it's available on the
blu-ray and you can buy it or
you know if you want to watch it for
free it's on to be free
with ads uh but yeah i thought it was
okay i thought it was pretty fun it's
like watching bloodsport
or under siege too you watch it
ironically
because we're too cool for that [ __ ] i
like it
i like it yeah i thought it was i
thought it was a lot of fun i watch all
crazy [ __ ] and [ __ ] laugh at it
yeah i just saw it um today i watched a
demolition man
on blu-ray and [ __ ] how [ __ ]
awesome that movie is that movie aged
very well
it did it had a lot of cool [ __ ] in it
wesley snipes he's basically he's being
[ __ ] simon of phoenix he's
better than the joker that's a good
movie it was
yeah it also predicted the future
predicted a lot of [ __ ] and then from
sandra bullocks was playing the [ __ ]
cop named huxley like aldous huxley yeah
and brave new world and everything
pretty cool i liked it oracle very
relevant very relevant to today
oracle mun says we're gen x we watch
everything ironically yeah yeah we kind
of do yeah i try not to
but you know then my natural snarkiness
it's almost it's like baked into that
generation i think yeah
i didn't really like demolition man that
much when it came out you know because
they made a lot of movies like that back
then but it
watching it today you're like man that
was a [ __ ] good flick
and another one that i want re-watched
recently that was a lot better than i
remembered was
um stallone's uh judge dredd it's a lot
better than i remembered it
when i saw it when it came out i didn't
think there was much to it you know but
i see it now
although i have to say that the most
recent movie that's dread that's good
too
kick ass yeah i mean they're different
but they are
they are they're both good but they're
both different uh sylvester stallone one
was
a movie of its time it kind of had a
comic book tone to it
kind of like superman superman one or
something you know
kind of a comic book maybe it gets no i
mean it's not the right one kind of like
kind of like robocop yeah it kind of had
a the same tone from
robocop one kinda thank you mango thank
you very much mango
he said i really enjoyed this matinee
review and the chat has been awesome
no thank you very much bro oh thank you
um
other than that that's about it it
probably is i think we've got them for
about 35 minutes
okay we can but yeah check out have a
couple of beers
get nice and liquored up yeah turn on
tubie
and watch masks mutilator yeah like i
said don't be mad at me for spoiling who
the killer is because she'll figure it
out it won't matter
it doesn't matter it's just something
you laugh at like i i i called it like
within five minutes
yeah i was like oh really that guy's the
killer is making the other guy look like
the killer i get it
because they were like so focused on
making the main guy like
so yeah i'm just saying all right so uh
we'll probably be back to do
either another movie review or sidetrack
tomorrow we'll find out
whatever we do if we find a new movie to
watch tonight we'll do it tomorrow
uh so we'll talk to you guys again
tomorrow and as usual thanks for
stopping by
thanks for contributions and uh
we'll see you later bye